[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Good morning.
Thank you all for coming.
It's great to see such
a full room today.
I'm delighted to
welcome Dianna Staaf.
Dianna Staaf fell in love with
cephalopods at the age of 10.
She began to keep them as
pets in a home aquarium
and learned to scuba dive in
order to meet more of them
in the wild.
She went on to study pygmy
octopuses in Santa Barbara,
cuttlefish in Australia,
reef squid in Bermuda,
and finally
completed her PhD on,
quote, "Reproduction and Early
Life of the Humboldt Squid,"
or, quote, "Squid Sex
and Babies," at Stanford.
Her first book titled "Squid
Empire: the Rise and Fall
of the Cephalopods,"
has been named
one of the best science books
of 2017 by NPR Science Friday.
She lives in San Jose
in the physical world
and at cephalopodiatrist.com
online.
Please join me in welcoming
to Google Dianna Staaf.
DIANNA STAAF: Thank you so much.
It's really
wonderful to be here.
I know it was probably hard to
take time away from your work
to come, and I
appreciate that everybody
was able to do that to be here.
And for anybody watching it
remotely or in the future,
thank you for taking time
out of whatever else you were
going to be doing to see this.
I am here to talk to
you about cephalopods,
which is a difficult word
to say all by itself.
And so we can just call
them squid, and octopus,
and relatives.
And in particular, the story
that I want to tell about them
is a story that parallels
the history of dinosaurs.
And the reason that
this particular story
about cephalopods has caught
my attention to the point
that I wrote a
whole book about it
is that I started to realize
that the deep, evolutionary
history of squid and
octopuses was even more
fascinating than
the famous dinosaurs
that we all know and love
from the age of three or four,
and yet nobody knows
anything about it.
So I'm going to tell you
today why cephalopods
are even better than dinosaurs.
And in particular,
trying to spark something
that I like to call the
Cephalopod Renaissance.
This is a reference to
something called the Dinosaur
Renaissance that happened
in the latter part
of the last century.
We often don't even
realize it today,
but dinosaurs used to be seen as
really slow, and really stupid,
and really boring.
And that was this view up here.
This drawing was done
in the late 1800s,
but the view persisted
into the early 1900s
as well that dinosaurs were
too heavy to even walk around.
They had to live in swamps.
They were too stupid to survive,
and so they were already
doomed by the time an asteroid
hit and ended their reign.
And so no one was actually
that interested in their lives
and behavior until
a scientist named
Bob Bakker in the '60s
started to describe dinosaurs,
and in particular one famous
dinosaur named deinonychus,
and realized that it moved
quickly, it was very active,
it was very energetic.
And this actually became
the whole view of dinosaurs
that we now know.
As complex creatures with
social lives and behaviors,
and all their relationships
with birds, and the feathers,
and the warm bloodedness.
And all of this stuff is
called the Dinosaur Renaissance
and gives us this
beautiful view of
the delightfully ferocious,
warm blooded, cuddly dinosaurs
that we know today.
And, of course, this
Dinosaur Renaissance
happened in the scientific
literature championed
by scientists, but it quickly
seeped out into popular culture
giving us all of these.
This is why we have Jurassic
Park and all of its sequels.
This is why we have
so many sticker
books full of dinosaurs and
video games full of dinosaurs.
Its because there was this
shift in scientific thinking
about dinosaurs realizing
how complex and interesting
their lives really were.
So I'm here to show you
the same thing happening
with cephalopods, except
they're even better.
And one of the ways in
which they're even better
is that they have so many
representatives around today
that we can learn from.
Of course, we have
representatives
of dinosaurs today.
We have birds.
And similarly to that,
we can think about
what do we have the squid and
the octopus that we have today,
and what makes
them what they are?
A lot of the things
that we think of
are tentacles, camouflage.
There's actually a cuttlefish
here hiding in the sand.
It's little arms are
coming down there
and it has two
little black eyes.
The amazing camouflage abilities
of these animals are legendary.
And, of course, they can also
squirt ink if that doesn't work
and they have to
get away quickly.
And it's all connected
to their intelligence.
Their very large brains.
Their ability to coordinate.
The camouflage, the behavior,
to coordinate all of those arms
and tentacles moving together.
It all has to be done by a very
complex central nervous system.
And these are all the
things that we know and love
about cephalopods today.
About squid and octopus.
And one of the things that
is most fascinating to me
about their evolutionary history
is that none of these things
originally made the
first cephalopod.
The very first cephalopod
was made by a shell.
A buoyant shell.
And that was what separated
the early cephalopods from all
of the other snails,
and mollusks,
and other clams and things that
were living on the sea floor.
And to understand
how this happened,
we have to go way, way, way
back in time because cephalopods
are twice as old as dinosaurs.
So we have to go before
humans, obviously,
but also way back
before the dinosaurs,
and way back before there
was anything on land.
So we're now talking
500 million years ago.
Land is completely
barren, except for algae.
Are there any phycologist
in the audience?
You don't even know
what phycology is.
It's great.
It's the study of algae.
And I always feel bad saying
that there's nothing on land
because technically there
were some little cells
of algae smooshing
around here and there.
But there was nothing
large and interesting.
Everything large and
interesting was in the ocean,
and this is what it looked like.
Trilobites mostly.
And more algae, but
larger algae this time.
All these big plants here.
And almost everything
was on the sea floor.
So even under water, there
weren't any large animals
swimming around.
This is way before
fish and sharks.
No marine reptiles,
no marine mammals.
And so anything
that was swimming
was just kind of a
little shrimpy thing.
And most of the large animals
were crawling on, or burrowing
in, or scrabbling around
over the sea floor
because that was the
interesting place where
all of the interactions
were taking place.
And one little fellow who was
doing this along with everybody
else is this little
snail-like creature
that's thought to be one
of the first cephalopods
or the first ancestors
of cephalopods.
And the shell of
this little fellow
shows us how they became
the wondrous creatures
that they turned into.
And it happened because--
this is diagrams.
Cross-sections of the shell.
So here's our little friend
still smooshing around
on the sea floor.
But you can see that
inside the shell
there are some little chambers.
The chambers filled
with the yellow color
are sectioned off, separated
from the rest of the animal,
and they're filled
with buoyant gas.
And once enough of
those chambers formed,
the gas in them was able to
offset the weight of the shell
and the weight of the animal and
lift it right up into the water
column.
So that's what you
see at the top there
is the first real,
true cephalopod that
had a chambered shell
with buoyant gas
inside the chambers.
It was able to move
around in the water column
and they were some of the first
animals to really be swimmers.
And not only were they swimmers,
but they could get enormous.
Because once the shell
is no longer heavy,
now the shell carries
its own buoyancy with it,
it can get arbitrarily large.
And so cephalopods literally
rose above the competition.
I like to say this is a
very authentic drawing
of the early Ordovician seas,
except for the scuba diver
who's sort of out of place.
But she's just there to
show scale to show you
how incredibly large
these animals got.
The straight shelled cephalopods
are going off of the screen.
They were large enough that
the shells would have reached
the entire length of this room.
And then we don't
even know if they
had tentacles, how many
tentacles they had,
how long those tentacles
might have been.
So they really were some
of the first sea monsters,
the first sea monsters
in the whole ocean, which
meant in the whole world
because there was still
nothing large on land.
And so on top here--
again, this time with a
snappily dressed men for scale--
we have [? cameraseris, ?] one
of those really long shelled,
straight shelled
early cephalopods.
And then this curl shelled
cephalopod down here
is a type of cephalopod
called an ammonite that
lived much later.
That one actually lived in
the oceans at the same time
as dinosaurs were
living on land.
Icthyosaurs were
swimming around.
If they were big enough,
they were probably
trying to eat these guys.
Mosasaurs were
probably eating them.
And you could see that the
shells got large enough
that a person could climb
inside of that shell.
They were really tremendous
throughout the hundreds
of millions of years that
they lived in the ocean.
And for most of
this time, they all
had these big shells that
carried their own buoyancy
around with them.
And so they were
sort of freed up
to move wherever they wanted,
to be as large as they
could possibly evolve to be.
And they were living
there, doing all this
at the same time--
both long before and also at
the same time as the dinosaurs
were doing all of their
crazy things on land.
And then what
really blows my mind
is that they faced
extinction at the same time.
At the end of the Cretaceous
when an asteroid smashed
into the planet and all
of the non-avian dinosaurs
went extinct, so did
most of the cephalopods.
It was a very bad day.
They don't know
exactly what happened.
We do know that the
asteroid hit, that it
changed the global climate.
It probably acidified the
surface areas of the oceans
tremendously.
There were probably lots of
fires all over the place.
It's still a matter
of active research
why this really bad day caused
such specific extinctions.
Because remember, not
everything went extinct.
It was not a really
bad day for everybody.
We still have all of our birds.
All of our avian dinosaurs.
And we still have
all of our squid,
and octopus, and
nautilus, and cuttlefish
that we talked about.
And so it is a very
interesting question
about why some of
these animals survived
one of the worst
days on the planet
and so many others went extinct.
And it makes it very
interesting to study
both of these
large famous groups
that faced extinction-- the
dinosaurs and the cephalopods.
Now, I have to
wonder-- so cephalopods
were huge, ancient monsters,
they lived before the dinosaurs
and through the time
of the dinosaurs,
and they had a horrible,
massive murder mystery
extinction at the same time.
So why aren't they as cool?
Why don't we know as much?
I mean, they are as
cool, but why don't we
think they're as cool?
Why don't we know
as much about them?
And the interesting
thing is the sort
of fossils they
leave are extremely
different from the sort of
fossils that a dinosaur leaves.
A dinosaur leaves--
interestingly,
cephalopod fossils are
actually way more abundant.
So this is just a picture
here of a single rock
that's crammed with
these coiled ammonites.
These are ancient
cephalopods that
lived at around the same
time as the dinosaurs
with these coiled shells.
And they're just
fossilized everywhere.
This is a single
dinosaur thighbone, which
is always a very exciting find.
To find even one bone
from a dinosaur skeleton.
And you would think
that if their fossils
are more abundant, that we
would know more about them.
But the abundance
of their fossils
caused an interesting
situation for many, many years.
Their fossils are so
abundant that geologists just
used them as time stamps.
This is a picture of sort of
a cross-section through rocks
showing you how rocks
get deposited in layers
and then the layers get eroded.
So if you go out digging for
fossils in different places,
you might dig through
different layers
and find different fossils.
And in this case, these
fossils are showing you
that even if you dig in very
different places in the world,
you might find the same
fossils from place to place.
And that can help you
know the age of the rocks
that you're digging in.
And those fossils that
are reliable enough
to tell you the age of
the rocks are digging in,
those are called index fossils.
And many, many index fossils
are cephalopods or ammonites
and the relatives of squid
because they're so abundant,
they're so diverse, and
they're so easily recognized.
A single shell can be
identified to species
quite easily by counting the
ribs and figuring out various--
just taking morphometrics.
Basically doing little
measurements and saying it's
wider than it is tall, or
it's fatter than it is tall,
and all of these things
will give you the species.
And so for a long time,
geologists were like,
these are super useful rocks.
They're the most useful
rocks in the world,
but they're not animals.
Nobody was thinking about
what were these things doing
when they were alive.
Ecologically
speaking, why did they
evolve these crazy shapes
and these intricate lines?
And some of them were spiky,
and some of them were tiny,
and some of them were big.
And nobody really thought
about those questions
because they were just
so useful as time stamps.
And then this book was published
in 2001 called "Ammonites."
It's a really little book.
It was published by
a couple of people
at the Natural History
Museum in London.
And they just asked a
very simple question.
What might these ammonites,
these ancient cephalopods,
have looked like
when they were alive?
And more importantly,
what were they doing?
What were they eating?
And who was eating them?
And this was kind of a first
step towards creating dioramas
like fourth graders
everywhere do with dinosaurs.
And you have the t-rex
jumping on the triceratops
and taking large bites of it.
And after this
book was published,
people started
publishing illustrations
like this in their
scientific papers.
Actually trying to recreate
the animals and think,
what would they have been doing?
This particular animal up
here is a kind of ammonite
that grows a recurved shell
sort of like a paperclip.
And it's been
puzzling scientists
for a really long time
thinking, what did they do?
Why would they bend
their shell back again?
It seems like it would be
really awkward for swimming.
And then this crazy Russian
scientist named [INAUDIBLE]
was like, well, maybe they
just used it like a paperclip.
If it's shaped like
a paperclip, maybe it
works like a paperclip.
And why didn't they
just hook themselves
on to some kelp or some
underwater driftwood
and live there?
Live a very sedentary life.
And so he drew this picture
and that got published,
and then other scientists
published angry diatribes
showing why that couldn't
possibly be the case.
It was great because
science has been proceeding
by leaps and bounds
because people are actually
thinking, talking about
it, building models
to see what can happen.
And so the other thing that is
helping to move this forward
is not just the
shift in perspective
that people are finally thinking
about what they would have
looked like, what the cephalopod
dioramas of the deep sea
should look like, but
there are new ways
to look at the fossils.
So technology has
proceeded to the point
where we can get
more information out
of those old fossils.
And all of these fossils
that I showed you
are all well and good.
They're beautiful.
It's easy to count ribs
and things like that,
but it doesn't tell you
very much about what
the animal was like.
If you look at an
articulated skeleton
of a t-rex or a brontosaurus,
you can drape flesh onto it
pretty easily.
You see where the neck was.
You see how many legs it had.
You see how long its tail was.
But all of the soft
parts of the cephalopod
are totally missing from
this kind of fossil.
They're just gone.
And we have no idea
where their mouth was
or what number of tentacles
they might have had.
But now paleontologists
are making friends
with medical imagery
technicians and putting rocks
into CT scanners, which
I'm told is, like,
everybody's favorite thing
when they go to the hospital
and find that there are fossils
being run through the CT
scanner and everybody gathers
around to see what's going on.
Because the great
thing is if you
look inside these
kinds of fossils,
you can actually start
to get information
about the soft parts
that's missing.
And in this case,
this particular fossil
was a straight
shelled cephalopod.
And the CT scanner
is not yet finding
how many tentacles it had,
but it is finding the mouth.
And there are some pretty
stunning images coming out.
This is straight out of a
paper in science, which is--
science papers are
incredibly condensed.
So I'm sorry to show you this
image that's like, ugh, too
much information.
But basically, A, on top, that's
a picture of the straight shell
that was put in the CT scanner.
B shows you a sort of
cross-sectional view of what
sort of the beginning
of the mouth
might have looked like
inside that shell.
And then these shapes
here that you're seeing
are the tongue of the animal.
Cephalopods, squid, and octopus,
and all of their cousins
have these really complex
tongues with a lot of teeth
on them called radula.
And these tongues of
these ancient cephalopods
seem to have been
really, really complex.
They were these sort
of folded up origami
shapes with little
tongues all over them
that look like they could
have been unfolded and used
almost like a spider's
web to catch plankton,
to catch little particles
and little animals
and things in the open ocean.
So this tells us--
and this here is sort
of a 3D reconstruction
of how that might have--
this colorful part up
there is the radula.
That tongue being unfolded
slowly from kind of a base, jaw
base where it would have
sat inside the animal.
And so this is really abstract
for most of us to look at.
But fortunately,
there are artists
who work with scientists to then
make reconstructions like this,
which doesn't show you
the radula unfortunately,
but it is showing you
this beak out of which
the radula would have unfolded.
And the whole
structure of the animal
is based around that
knowledge of it being
something that eats plankton.
A lot of other reconstructions
think of these ancient animals
as being active predators.
Carnivores, like squid
and octopus are today.
But this discovery of
that complicated radula
that would have just filtered
plankton out of the water
has helped a new interpretation
arise thinking, like, OK.
They didn't have
really long arms that
were muscular for
grabbing food, they just
had this little
web of arms maybe.
And then this beak that
could open up and sort
of slurp up all of the
little yummy bits and pieces.
And they probably-- this
[INAUDIBLE] at least
would not have been
a very good swimmer.
It would have just sort of
gently drifted here and there
picking up food, which is
a different thing that none
of the living cephalopods do.
There aren't really any plankton
feeding squid or octopus.
They tend to be mostly
active predators.
And so in a way it's
sort of like looking
at ancient dinosaurs
and being like,
well, we don't really
have any t-rexes anymore.
But if you can imagine a
chicken getting that big
and being carnivorous,
and what would it be like?
So this sort of nuanced ability
to interpret the fossils
is really growing,
creating, what seems to me,
to be a wonderful time for
a Cephalopod Renaissance
for the extinct cephalopods.
And these are more
artist reconstructions
that are a little
bit more fantastical.
But again, like
dinosaurs, we don't really
have any idea what
color they were.
So paleo artists can just
kind of go wild with it.
And all of these shapes
are completely realistic.
There are ancient
cephalopod fossils
that grew in
corkscrews with spikes
that had these weird
recurved-- this
is sort of a cousin of the
paperclip one over here
that just were super
irregular knots.
And we're still
trying to figure out
why they had all these
super weird shapes.
And while paleontologists are
working on this to figure out
what was going on, it's kind of
a perfect time for the public
to become excited
about cephalopods
because all of our
modern cephalopods--
squid and octopus
around us today--
are going through boom times.
There is what's been referred
to as a global proliferation
of cephalopods.
And these figures here
are from a paper that
was published in 2016
that was kind of a review
paper gathering
data from fisheries
and from scientific
surveys from octopuses,
cuttlefish, squid, ones
that live close to the shore
and ones that live
further out in the deep,
and showing that all of
them averaged together
are trending up.
And we are living in a very--
we're very bullish on
cephalopods in the oceans
these days.
And the reason seems to be
that all of these animals
have evolved away
from that heavy shell.
They don't have a big
external shell anymore.
And it's created an extremely
flexible group of animals
because they can grow quickly.
They don't have to
build a heavy shell.
They have a lot of babies
that can adapt very quickly
to their changing environment.
And that adaptability
and flexibility
seems to be a lot of
what's driving this boom.
That and the fact
that humans have
been fishing a lot of their
main predators out of the ocean.
And so they're sort
of like, thanks
for removing all of
the fish, and now we
will go wild, situation.
And, of course,
there are t-shirts
that you can buy
celebrating this dominance
of the cephalopods.
I forgot to wear mine today,
but you can look them up online.
However, there are
always some exceptions
to this sort of optimistic
view of the cephalopod future.
And I have to mention that there
are a few species that are not
doing especially well that are
actually listed as endangered.
And they are deep
sea octopuses that
live in the deep,
cold waters where
they take a very
long time to grow
and they reproduce
only a few eggs.
And worst of all, they
happen to have neighbors
that are very delicious.
So even though you've
probably never heard of these
octopuses-- they don't have
common names because nobody
talks about them commonly--
but they live on
seamounts in the deep sea
where orange roughy fish
and scampi shrimp also live.
And people like to
eat those things.
And when people throw down
nets into the deep sea
to get the shrimp and
the fish, they also
catch these octopuses.
And that's why these
particular species
are considered endangered
is because many of them
have been accidentally
brought up in these nets
and the populations
are suffering.
And even the squid that are
booming throughout the oceans
and doing really
well have some risks.
These are a couple of
papers that came out
showing that there are
problems with ocean
acidification affecting the
early development of squid.
So even though right now they
seem to be doing really well,
the oceans are changing.
They're getting warmer
and warmer and the water
is getting more and more acidic.
And those things might,
in the near future,
cause that boom trajectory
to flatten out or even
get depressed a little bit
depending on how things change,
how much we decide to
change things or not
let them go on as normal.
And then, of course, we
still have one cephalopod
with an external shell--
nautilus.
So how are they doing?
Well, I think of nautiluses
as sort of a cautionary tale
because they're so beautiful.
They still have
that external shell.
They're the last cephalopod
with an external shell.
And they have these
beautiful tiger stripes.
And you can buy them
anywhere, it turns out.
They're not even
very expensive, which
is a problem because if
you can buy them anywhere
and people will pull them out
of the ocean more and more
to make money, and then
there won't be any nautiluses
anymore.
And this has become
enough of a problem
that in 2017, CITES, which is
the international treaty that
regulates all the big endangered
species like rhinoceros horn
and elephant tusks has
decided to start regulating
the trade of nautilus
shells as well, which
is very encouraging.
And it's being considered for
being listed on the Endangered
Species Act here in the
US, which would also
cause more protections to be
put in place so fewer of them
could be imported.
And it would hopefully
lead to a longer survival
time for this lineage
of shelled cephalopods.
The last ones with
that buoyant shell.
And this listing
or this possibility
of listing cephalopods here
is open for public comment.
And I went and read all
of the public comments
that people had posted, and
one of them in particular
struck me.
I thought I would
bring it to you.
This as neuroethologist
named Heike Neumeister.
So neuroethologist means she
studies brain and behavior
and how those things
are connected.
And she commented that,
"Nautilus represents a window
to the past.
A unique opportunity
to understand
the evolution of the brain,
including its vulnerability.
It's protection is not
only important for us,
but indeed is a moral
imperative for mankind."
So she was of the opinion that
she was presenting this idea
that because we have
nautiluses still around today
and because their history
goes back 500 million years
before the dinosaurs, they
are really a one of a kind
opportunity to understand
how this incredible brain
that we see in
octopus and squid,
how it evolved in contrast to
other members of the species.
And so I think this is
a really beautiful way
to connect the study of
the ancient cephalopods
and my mission to get everybody
to find them to be just as
cool as dinosaurs with
what's going on currently
with the living cephalopods
that we have here today.
It's a really deep lineage here.
This is the history going all
the way back to the Cambrian
500 million years ago.
Here's our old buddy with the
very first little chambers
in its shell, all the way
through the really long
straight shelled ones.
This is not exactly
to scale because I
didn't have just sort of
infinite room to go off here.
And then in the early
coiled cephalopods,
all these super weird shapes
of ammonoids that proliferated
and then went extinct at
the end of the Cretaceous.
And you'll see over here
that the nautilus has
been just chugging along from
its ancestors all the way back
here towards really
the root of the tree.
And it's still a lot of open
questions, a lot of mystery.
Have they changed in a way that
we can't tell from the fossils?
Are they really these
unchanged, living fossils?
There's a lot of interesting
work to be done there.
And meanwhile, all of
the other cephalopods,
the octopuses, the
squid, the cuttlefish,
are doing all of
their own things.
A beautiful proliferation that
we're seeing in the oceans
today.
And by comparing all of this
stuff, all of the deep time
history with all of
the modern diversity,
we're really in
a beautiful place
to understand this
group like never before.
And it's a group that
is uniquely suited
to sort of shedding light
on all of life on Earth,
because it's really the
farthest group from us primates
that has developed
intelligence, and curiosity,
and problem solving skills.
And by comparing the way we
do those things with the way
cephalopods do those
things, we can really
get a holistic understanding.
So I just wanted to thank
you all finally for coming,
and take some questions.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks a lot for the great talk.
I had a question.
How hard would it be to
breed and farm nautilus?
DIANNA STAAF: The question
is how hard would it
be to breed nautilus?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
Because you're saying that
the shells are so beautiful
and people start importing
them and [INAUDIBLE]
I'm thinking as
an alternative, we
could maybe start farming
them for the shells.
DIANNA STAAF: Yeah.
Aquaculture is often
seen as a solution
if we want more of something
but the wild harvest
isn't available.
Can we make them ourselves?
Nautilus are a really
interesting group
in that regard, an
interesting species
because they've only just
successfully been bred at all.
Like, although people have
been keeping the animals
in aquariums for
a long time, they
haven't been successfully
breeding and laying eggs.
And just in the last year or two
at the Monterey Bay Aquarium,
they've been keeping them and
they've actually laid the eggs
and the eggs have
actually hatched,
which are two separate
challenges that
both had to be overcome.
But there's still a huge gap
in having hatchlings and having
those grow up to
be breeding adults.
So I think it's possible.
I hope that it happens
because, for many reasons.
One is that it would
just be very interesting.
But it seems like they're
a very finicky species,
and they're just very specific
about the water requirements
and the food requirements.
And so I believe right now the
aquarists at the Monterey Bay
Aquarium are trying
to figure out
what to feed the babies to
get them to grow up healthy.
And it takes a long time because
even with good conditions,
it takes them up to 20
years to reach maturity.
So that's getting to
be several aquarists
lifetimes of practice.
But I think it will get there.
I think it will be very cool.
AUDIENCE: Thanks for the talk.
My question is, you
said these creatures are
found in deep sea?
DIANNA STAAF: Many of them.
Yeah.
Not all.
AUDIENCE: And how
have they adapted
to-- because there's a lot of
water pressure that is deep.
Can you talk
something about that?
DIANNA STAAF: Yeah.
It's a great question.
Are you more interested
in the living ones,
or the extinct ones, or both?
AUDIENCE: All of it.
DIANNA STAAF: OK.
Yeah.
So it's a great question.
The forms that
have buoyant shells
are, of course, always
somewhat limited
because they have
gas in their shell.
And so if they go too
deep, that can implode.
So even modern nautiluses
and modern cuttlefish
which have an
internal shell that
still has gas chambers in
it are limited by depth.
So cuttlefish, because
their internal shell
has quite weak walls, they
can't go much deeper than 100
or maybe 200 feet.
They're quite shallow
because of that.
Well, shallow for an open
ocean animal, not for us.
Nautilus can go a
little bit deeper.
They can get to about
800 feet for most ones,
and that's because the
shell is much, much thicker.
And the limits of
the extinct ones
are, of course,
hard to calculate.
And it's always a
little bit tricky
to know where they lived because
the shells sometimes move
around before being fossilized.
And so if the fossilized
shells are found in sediment,
that shows that it
was in the deep sea.
Well, does it mean that the
animal lived in the deep sea
or does it mean the animal
lived above the deep sea?
But they're thought,
many of them
especially-- let me see
if I can go back here.
This is an interesting--
where are my ammonoids?
There.
These guys.
In particular, many of
these ammonites had--
sorry.
I probably wasn't
supposed to touch that--
had these really complicated
walls between the chambers.
So all of the squiggles
that you see here
are like if each
chamber's wall between was
made of sort of tissue paper
and you just crumpled it up.
And it's still sealed
between the chambers
and held the gas
from place to place,
but it had this
incredibly complex line.
And it's thought that that
might have sort of somehow
spread out the pressure and
allowed them to go even deeper.
And so there's some
paleontologists
actually working
right now on kind
of reconstructing
these as models
and figuring out what
pressure they might
have been able to survive at.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
DIANNA STAAF: I don't think--
let's see.
I don't think any of them have
been estimated to live deeper
than about 1,000 feet.
So I don't think any of
the shelled cephalopods
could have lived
in what we think
of as the real abyssal deep sea.
The first cephalopods
to colonize
that area would have been
the ones that lost the shell.
And, in fact, it's thought
that the ancestors of squid,
who had evolved away from having
an external shell-- and even
their internal shell doesn't
have gas chambers anymore.
It's just like this sort of
thin, stiff rod that gives them
a little bit of structure.
So they are basically
insensitive to pressure
because they're incompressible.
There's no gas spaces.
There's no gas bladder.
There's nothing.
And so it's thought that one
of the reasons they might have
survived the end of
Cretaceous impact
is that they had a refuge
in the deep sea where
things didn't change so much.
And there are still
many squid living
in the very deep sea today.
AUDIENCE: Speaking of squid,
I'm an octopus person,
but I also love
the Humboldt squid.
I was wondering what drew
you to that for your PhD.
And can you talk a
little bit about that?
DIANNA STAAF: I
would be happy to.
It's a lovely question.
So the Humboldt squid was
the subject of my PhD.
And it was somewhat
accidental because I
went into looking for graduate
programs and PhD advisors just
being kind of a
huge cephalopod nut.
I was like, I'll
work on anything.
Are you doing bobtail squid?
Are you doing pygmy octopuses?
Whatever it is.
And in Monterey,
there's a marine station
that is affiliated with
Stanford University.
Some of you may
already know this.
It's right next to the
Monterey Bay Aquarium
and it's called
Hopkins Marine Station.
And there's a squid lab there.
And the scientist who
runs that lab, Bill Gilly,
was starting up a whole
research program on Humboldt
squid at about the
same time that I was
applying to graduate school.
And so I met with him
and he talked to me a bit
about the squid.
And I was like, I have never
heard of these guys before,
but they sound really cool.
And it was also--
they were just starting
to expand their range,
so it was a really interesting
time to be working on them.
It was a, it's a large species.
It still is a very
large species.
The adults can get
about as big as me.
And it's also the biggest squid
fishery in the whole world.
So of all of the
different species of squid
that people eat,
little calamari,
these big squid steaks
that are on Humboldt
squid, it's fished by
the million tons a year.
And most of that is in South
America, Central America,
and Mexico.
But in the early
2000s, we were starting
to find them on the California
coast and even up into Alaska.
They are getting
really far north.
And so it was a really fun time
to be a scientist studying them
because we would get
calls from people,
just, like, fishermen,
we caught a huge squid.
Is it a giant squid?
What is it?
Can you eat it?
Can I sell it?
What can I do with it?
And so it was just
a really neat time.
And we were trying to figure
out why they were there,
what they were doing.
I ended up working a lot with
the babies and reproduction.
And my main question
there was thinking, OK.
We know that there
are adults coming
up north into California, which
is very cold water for them.
They're used to the warmer
water in the Gulf of California.
Can they have babies up here?
Basically, are we going
to get a reproducing
population establishing itself
as the range is expanding?
And interestingly,
at the same time
as I was figuring out that the
little babies needed warm water
and they were actually very
finicky-- they're teeny.
This is the hilarious thing.
So you have a grown
up as big as me,
and when their babies hatch,
they're like a grain of rice.
And they're quite finicky,
and they need warm water,
and they need very special food.
And it's kind of the
nautilus problem.
We couldn't feed them anything.
We would give them
everything we would think of,
and they would just
starve in the lab.
All right.
Go back to the ocean
and find whatever
you were meant to find.
And it seems
interesting that while I
was finding that they had this
very particular need as babies,
the invasion, as everyone
was calling it, of California
just kind of slowed down.
And eventually, now
fishermen off California
and further north hardly
ever find Humboldt squid.
They're pretty much
all retreated back
to their native range in Mexico.
And even there, they've
gotten a lot smaller.
So it's been fun
to see in practice
the sort of flexibility
that I talked about
because this
species, as a whole,
is still doing really well,
but you can see them responding
year by year and
even season by season
to the way the ocean changes.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Thanks for the awesome talk.
So this is a strange
question, but given
the absence of preserved
soft body features,
how do we know that extinct
cephalopods even had tentacles?
DIANNA STAAF: That's
a great question!
How do we even know
that they had tentacles?
I'm going to go to the
short answer is, we don't.
Maybe they didn't
have tentacles at all.
And in particular, these
guys, these really early ones,
I mean, I think that in a
way, the only reason people
draw them with
tentacles is to show
that we know they're cephalopods
because that's the defining
feature.
But they might not have
had tentacles at all.
Interestingly, by
this point here,
which is the
branching point where
you get the lineage
of the nautiluses
and then the lineage going to
all of your modern cephalopods,
we're pretty sure that they
would have had tentacles
by then because tentacles--
and the tentacles
come from the foot.
So the ancestral
cephalopod was related
to a snail, which has a big
foot that it oozes around on.
And so we know because
of studying the way
they develop in the
egg that what happens
is that foot splits
into tentacles quite
early on in development.
And that happens in embryonic
nautilus and in embryonic squid
at the same time and
with the same number.
So it's always 10 to begin with.
Even with a nautilus
that eventually gets up
to 60 or 90 tentacles.
And because that trait
seems to be so conserved,
it's thought that it probably
goes way back to this split.
That there's an ancestral
cephalopod trait
of having a foot that
divides into 10 tentacles.
And then that evolved in
nautiluses at some point
to be just this, like,
plethora of tentacles.
And in squid, two of those--
and they were all
equal length as well.
Because you do get a few
fossils up or over here
that have these 10
equal length tentacles.
And so two of them in squid
became much longer and elastic.
Two of them in
octopuses disappeared.
But even in octopuses,
we know that
the ancestral characteristic
was to have 10.
And so that's sort
of the answer.
So we're pretty sure that
by here they had tentacles,
and some point in
here probably evolved.
It would have been useful
if you think about being
a snail up in the water.
How do you get your food?
Or maybe you just have
a really flexible foot.
AUDIENCE: Thank you
for the amazing talk.
Question about chromatophores
and when they evolved,
and if there is a way to
tell whether they evolved.
And then the second part of
the question, the radula,
is that just a mollusk
trait and that's
how they know that that's
what the tongue looked
like when they were going
back and creating imagery?
Or how do they tell?
DIANNA STAAF: Right.
So two different traits.
The chromatophores, the
color changing ability,
and the radula.
So I'll take the radula
first since there's
more physical evidence for it.
The radula is a molluscan trait.
So you'll see radulas
in snails, even
in clams, all kinds
of different mollusks.
And, in fact, all the
different snail radulas
are useful because snails eat
in a lot of different ways.
And I don't mean just
garden snails at this point.
There are a lot
of marine snails.
And there are marine snails
that scrape food off rocks,
and there are marine
snails that are predators
that eat other fish, and there
are marine snails that float,
actually float through the
water and catch plankton.
And so looking at all of
those different radulas
is the main way that
the paleontologists
have begun to look at ammonite
radulas, cephalopod radulas.
Kind of say, what would
it have been good for?
Does it look more like the
snail that eats plankton,
or the snail that eats
algae, or these things?
And so the radula itself
is usually not preserved
independently as a fossil
because it's quite delicate
and it probably
just falls apart.
And so if I'm remembering
right, the only real radulas
that are found are when
they're inside a shell.
And so either the shell
has to be physically broken
and then it's sort of just
luck whether you actually
find the radula or whether
you've destroyed it
by breaking the shell, or you
see it by doing essentially,
like, an electronic
dissection with a CT scan.
And then for the chromatophore,
that's a very good question.
We think that probably
that amazing skin,
that amazing color changing skin
evolved around the same time
that the shell, shell,
shell, shell went
internal, which is in this
lineage called the colioids.
And this is one
of these fun facts
that I only learned when I
started researching my book.
A PhD did not teach me this.
But when you're doing all
this etymological research
because people
ask you questions,
colioid means scabbard.
So this whole group is named
because their bodies became
like the scabbards
for their shell.
It was internalized
and covered up.
And so once the
shell goes internal,
which is this little
light colored thing,
it's still chambered,
it's still buoyant,
it was still quite
substantial for a long time,
but it was no longer
something you could hide in.
And so at that
point, it would have
been extremely
advantageous for the skin
to develop some
method of protection.
And so we think
that that's probably
when both camouflage
and ink sacks are
likely to have
evolved, but there's
precious little in the fossil
record about either one.
AUDIENCE: So putting on
my third grader hat here,
do we call them tentacles
because there are 10 of them?
DIANNA STAAF: Oh, that's
such a good question!
It is technically wrong to
call them all tentacles.
Trying to find a gentler
word [INAUDIBLE]..
It's wrong.
They're all arms really.
And the word tentacles is
best to reserve for those two
really elastic ones.
So a squid or a cuttlefish,
if you ever maybe seen
a video of them catching prey,
or you can go home and look one
up, they have
their arms that are
just always the same
length and maybe they might
grab slow moving prey with it.
But if they need to catch
a fish or something that's
really fast, they have
these elastic tentacles
that go zoom, and catch
it, and bring it back in.
It's like milliseconds.
It's really, really fast.
And those are the tentacles.
So squid have them,
cuttlefish have them,
octopuses do not have them.
Technically, squid
and cuttlefish
are the only ones
with true tentacles.
But you can remember them
not because of the 10 part,
but because the word tentacle
is longer than the word arm.
And tentacles are
longer than arms.
AUDIENCE: I have
one more if it's OK.
So since the seas
are acidifying,
I had a question
about the shells.
Because you're saying that
the [INAUDIBLE] squids
and octopuses are
having a problem.
Are they a calcium
carbonate shell,
or are they silica based?
DIANNA STAAF: They're
calcium carbonate.
Even the cuttle bone, which
is the internal shell.
And the squid, for the most
part, is not even calcified.
So that's one of the
reasons that squid
seem to be a bit more resilient
to ocean acidification is
they don't have very much
that's actually calcified.
But the Nautilus shell and the
cuttlefish shell are calcium.
Interestingly, there
is one other place
that all of the cephalopods
have a bit of calcium carbonate
that's very sensitive
to acidification,
and it's these little
bones in their ears.
Teeny little bones
called statelates that
help them tell up from down.
We actually have similar
little teeny tiny bones
in our ear that rock
around and they're
what make you sick
on merry go rounds
and how you know
when you're facing up
and when you're pointed down.
And the development of
those teeny little bones
in cephalopods seems to be quite
affected by acidified waters.
And so there's some risk
that we might end up
with oceans full of sort
of disoriented, lost,
squid that can't figure out
which way is up and down.
We haven't gotten
there yet, though.
So fingers crossed.
SPEAKER 1: Well,
Thank you, Dianna.
Thank you, everyone, for coming.
Let's give one more
round of applause.